a belarusian sprinter christina
simeone simanuskaya
was granted a polish humanitarian visa
while seeking political asylum after she
refused to board a flight
back to her home country from the tokyo
games this is pretty wild man her home
country
wanted her to wanted to pull her out of
the olympic games
and so she asked for help on instagram
uh and here she is right here here's her
statement
and she asked the olympic internation
the international olympic committee to
get involved and help her out
you know her own country didn't like
some of the ways she was representing
them
and they they said this is a no-go
we're going to pull you out of here and
uh and she didn't want that so she asked
for help while she was away from belarus
she asked for help
and so now poland came along polish
power
and they're letting her drop over there
into warsaw
and you know this is the type of thing
this to me
is an act of
like speaking out against types of
oppression
you know this to me is you know you have
a
we've had a different american um
olympians you know they have some new
lady the other day
she got it looks like a piece of king
cake her hair has kind of died up and
she you know just talking about
oppression from the metal stand i don't
even think she won first place either i
think she was silver
first of all i think you should be you
should have to get first place to
to talk about the oppression and also if
you're in america
there's no there's not oppression
i don't feel like there's oppression you
know i've met people from every race
and every gender
and even animals look at air bud
dude in some countries you know no
offense for
you know riley mao but in some countries
dude that
you know you go to some of these more
like kennel snacking continents and
things would be different that thing's a
movie star over here
you know so when a lot of these people
are just talking about oppression
but they're literally standing in a
place where they're able to say whatever
they want
and can still go back to their own
country
i think it's a perfect example of uh
seeing her
this is a real example of what like
oppression and control
uh by our country really looks like what
do you think riley on any of this have
you seen any of this you don't know
about it
i haven't okay
um but yeah i think i'm just over the
you know the look at me when you're
living in an amazing life
it's really hard to uh
to say that the place you're living it
in the platform you're living it in
is oppressing you i mean i think we all
feel somewhat pressured
and struggle through society
but there needs to be struggle
for everyone there needs to be some
pressure
um but yeah
uh this is this is something that is
real
when now you can't even go back home
because you spoke freely
i bet if that was the case for some of
the american athletes
uh i bet that they would have a
different a
understanding of oppression and then be
a different tone i think
but what do i know you know what i'm
saying i'm just one human
who's ejaculated less than 11 hours ago
so and not really proud of it
you know hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one